hi everyone my name is jeremy and
today i'm going to talk about a project
called jupiter light so it will be a mix
of
jupiter
web assembly and python so
um
first of all
i'm currently uh working at konstack as
a technical director
and at quan stack we also we do a lot of
open source
so mostly on the member ecosystem
and the jupiter ecosystem so i'm also a
core developer
in jupiter so we help maintain
projects like jupiter lab
voila
dashboards uh jupyter servers widgets
a lot of jupiter
and um
yeah and a couple of us are really
active in uh in the triple ecosystem so
if you are using tools in jupiter
world you probably uh
be talking to us on github and things
like this
so you might be wondering how is
jupiter light different compared to
normal jupiter because here i have a
couple of cells so i can just you know
run them
and i get
you know like what i would get in a
normal
uh jupiter notebook but the thing is um
jupiter light is a little bit different
and to
get an idea of this we can start from
this repo so this repo is the
repo for the um
this talk and
if you scroll down you see that at the
very bottom there is a link that ends
with github.io and this is pretty much
uh the thing you have for
when you host something on github pages
which lets you host
uh static files on uh to make your
websites or anything else so if you
click on that and you see that we get
redirected to a
jupyter lab
ui and it boots in seconds so
this is one aspect of jupiter light you
get you know very easy and quick access
to your
interactive
computing environment
because in the end actually
jupiter light is also published to pipi
as a python package
and the jupyter ici is pretty much just
a static site generator so
you know like you would be using jekyll
for your blog or something similar you
can use jupyter lite to create your own
jupyter website so
with this um in place it means that you
can create your own in a couple of
minutes so if you just go through this
repo
we made this template the demo repo it's
a product template on github
so if you look at this uh
screencast here there is a normally this
little
use this template button
here and
just in couple of minutes you activate
the github pages and you have your own
website
so that is very very useful if you want
to have a very lightweight jupyter
front-end
running in a browser you don't need to
set up any server you don't need to
open a terminal run a command line or
anything like this
um you don't even need to install python
or any other packages locally so skip
all of this
and you can even add this little batch
that looks like this yellow thing so for
example uh you have it on your remy here
and if you click on that you can
redirect your users uh to your jupyter
website
so
um since it's a static website
let's do this it's easy to deploy we
have a bit of documentation so if you go
to the docs on jupyter lite
here we detail how you can host your own
or used hosted environments to deploy
your thing so it could be
on github pages gitlab pages read the
docs
versus netlify
many others and actually
for the main repo that the main lab repo
we use read the docs so if you go to the
this url here you're going to be using a
website
uh
based on the main branch
and deploy to read the docs
so
before continuing i just wanted to do a
little bit of history just to highlight
some of the prior art um so in the past
there was a
project called drive by nick baldwick
who is now a contributor of a jupiter
light but also in jupiter in many many
places
and he decided this work with the same
kind of motivation trying to have like a
static website um but at the time we
didn't have
the thing we were going to talk about
later web assembly paradigm and all this
so it was it was there but it was more
of an experiment so
then came uh something that i wanted to
experiment with it's called the p5
notebook
so it's based there the idea was to have
something like a minimal notebook ui but
very focused for
p5.js which which is a
javascript library to draw stuff on the
canvas that runs in a browser so the
idea was to use jupylab components and
build something very very simple and
very very minimal so they could be used
by people who want to learn to code and
things like this
we also have another project called
baston by roman cassatti who is using
the classic
notebook which is now
duplicated but
it's also interesting because they they
managed to also deploy it for
educational purposes so they have a
couple of users there so it's great to
see jupiter used in education
and uh also wanted to highlight uh two
other things so
uh one is starboard and the other is
observable those two are not strictly
jupiter but they are still interesting
because
they use different approaches so they
can mix languages for example with
starboard and observable is more like
browser native so it's a bit more
towards javascript even though you can
also run
other languages if you want to so these
are out there and they all have you know
the pros and cons so it's still
just to get an
idea of where jupiter light
fits in all of this so if we go back to
jupiter light
it's pretty much
a combination of jupyter lab and jupyter
notebook when it comes to the user
interfaces
so
you have
the jupyter notebook 7
ui so
this is pretty much what we see right
now so gpu notebook 7 is going to be the
next
major version
for jupiter notebook and it's going to
be built
using jupiter components and this is
pretty much what you see here so it just
looks the same as jupyter notebook
6 also called the classic notebook
and
you also have
jupiter lab
so that's the one we we looked at before
you can
work with files
so if you go here you can even you know
open plots
open um
yeah icons
you can also open
geojson if you want
also notebooks
so that's the presentation i'm currently
showing here and this is um
yeah so you can have like the
notebook open and then you can uh
interact with them like this like if you
were using a
um
normal let's say normal jupiter on your
machine and
yeah so the cool thing is that
we are able to reuse a lot
really a lot of things coming from the
lab ecosystem
and for example the
uh the themes so here we have a jeep
lite knight theme
that's a third party
theme that we can actually
use and these
settings are also persisted
in your browser so if you reload the
page
they they stay
so let's go back to light
uh what else
yeah we have also uh there is also
consoles uh in jupyter lab so here we
have the javascript kernel so if you do
uh
something like this
then you get
some interactive computing with
javascript but also with python and
other languages
um
yeah and also you um
you can change the languages so in japan
there is uh ongoing effort to localize
the interface and
uh jupyterlight is just able to reuse
this as is so it's very really great
great because
all of the
work is happening upstream and um and
light is just able to reuse the same set
of tools so here we switch to um to
french and now it's in french
we go back to english
yeah
and um this localization effort is
really like crowdsourced so it's really
great because it's also uh translators
helping
for all of the languages
and maybe one more thing i can show is
um
third-party extensions so
let's say you have a set of users and
you want to introduce them to
the lab interface so there is this
extension by
frederick conoval who
wrote this it's called gplab tour and uh
you can give a tour of the interface so
it's pretty useful especially with light
because if you create your website and
you want to guide your users
you can use this kind of
of extensions and they are designed for
twitter but they also work with jupiter
light
which is great um yeah
so let's stop and let's go back here
so once again
jupiter light is really standing uh on
the shoulders of giants so
it's really built from the the ground up
so it's just like an another application
um
but um really mostly reusing triple a
components so there is a lot of um
work going on in egypt lab
ecosystem so jupiter light is just
reusing as much as possible from that
and um the the kernels they run in the
browser but they still communicate to
the front end using the the gpu protocol
so it's still the same protocol under
the hood which is great because it's all
based on standards and
it um it interacts really well with um
everything else so here you have a kind
of a picture of you know ipython
libraries like bq plot madrid lib and
also
python and so on
so yeah
so we usually like to
uh refer to jupyte as a was empowered
jupiter running in a browser
and wasm is the short for a web assembly
and if you go to the
mozilla developer network
documentation here so
awesome webassembly is um it's kind of a
new thing it's been there for a couple
of years
and what it says is like it can run on
the modern web browsers
and it's also
near native performance um and provides
languages such as
cc plus plus rust
so that they can
target the web
and
designed to run alongside javascript
which is
great because jupiter light is
javascript and we're going to see that
uh jupiter lab is actually uh
based also on
a python kernel built on top of pilodide
so paradide
is a python or actually see python
and the scientific stack compiled to
webassembly so python is in c and we saw
that
c is one of the languages that can
compare to web assembly so
pi dot project
does
this and um
jupiter light adds a little extra layer
on top of this to be able to
integrate that as a kernel that can be
used in
in the interface so here i can run the
code and we see that
python is a python 3.9
because it's still using pilot 019
020 landed yesterday not updated yet but
it will be soon
it's also using ipython so ipython runs
in jupiter light so here
if you import something that doesn't
exist you get some nice error
there is also basic support for code
completion
you can get some help i like like you
would do a normal notebook
um some magics are also supported like
the history
um and one thing that is nice also about
paradight is that
they provide a nice integration with the
browser and with javascript just like it
said in the uh
webassembly
snippet above so here we can actually
use the fetch
method from the browser and use it
to fetch data from
somewhere else and
we combine that combining that with um
this kind of environments where we have
you know viewers for json this is really
great because you can start exploring
your uh your request using this json
viewer and you can search for
fields and things like this so
yeah
that's it so
visualizations matplotlib is
shipped by default in pi data so you can
use it to do plots
but since plotly has a
jupilab extension we can also use it in
jupiter light so here you'll notice that
you need to actually still install them
a little bit on the fly like this so
that's
one thing that is a bit different
compared to a normal jupiter
so if we do this
we can then create a broadly graph
that is interactive
and there is also another library that
is interesting is out there i can create
these
graphs and then you can save them to
your
machine
geo json for example is also another
example so
here we point to the bcc in berlin
so that was for like more static graphs
and now it's let's talk about
interactive
widgets
so ipad widgets also works i can
interact with them
if you link this one and we moved
the slider it moves there too
and custom widgets also work so here we
have bq plot i can change the color
you know change the graph
create a new one and then you can update
the data and it updates automatically so
all of this is still again all in the
browser and still again uh reusing error
you know the extensions as they are
distributed
another one that is interesting is ipad
canvas
so here we're going to create a game of
life
so by canvas is a library that lets you
use the
browser canvas from python
and draw something on that so using
python so here we
draw
like the starting state of a game of
life
and
actually it's a good opportunity to also
show you another extension that is
pretty neat
it's called sticky land and
here you see if you click on that you
get this your sticky cell here so you
can
drag and drop it here so
hide the
input and you can continue with this it
stays so it's quite useful again it was
made for jupiter but it works also with
jupiter light and then we
run that cell and then you get your
thing output updated
and you can continue scrolling or do
something else
okay so let's close it so that was
python uh powered by pyrodied
um but now let's talk about another kind
of kernels
um so seuss is a jupiter project and
it's a framework for
uh authoring um jupiter kernels and it's
written in c plus plus and there are a
couple of candles uh using seuss excuse
kling is actually
c plus plus in a notebook so if you
haven't tried it
it's uh
fun so you can try
that but that one doesn't work yet in
light but maybe soon
[Music]
and there is a blog post about the work
that
thorson did to make seuss work in
jupiter light so here i would like to i
wanted to demo one of them which is a
sequel light
it was a
made by mariana
and then torsten took it and pretty much
made it work with webassembly so that's
uh
that's great because then we have this
example notebook so
let me
maybe
yeah let's clear outputs first
so we can create databases um
tables
insert data
uh select the data
insert mode data select select
and you see that it renders using the
the jupyter renders so this is like html
which is nicer to visualize
and with a
sequel light kernel
it's also interesting because there is
support for vega so you can even have
this static charts in line in your
notebook so that's quite useful because
then you can
visualize your data and then download
the
png or svg so yeah
so there are a couple of kernels that
are compatible with gyptonite at the
moment
yeah there is also javascript and p5 but
those are a bit different because you
know javascript is native in the browser
so a bit easier to get them to work
there is also ren which is also a
subspace calendar
kernel just for you know testing
and there's also lua which is uh also
working in uh in jupiter light
so injector light you
uh you can work with files so here we
saw that we have
the the file browser uh on the right and
um
and
gpu lite actually lets you kind of ship
a set of
notebooks and files by default when you
generate the website and
then you can uh edit them
in your
in your browser or you can create new
ones so you can create a new notebook
here and you can save it you can open a
close it and then you can open it again
and it stays if you reload the page it
will be persisted to
your storage so it could be indexed cb
if it's available or it will be a local
storage otherwise
it's still a bit clunky right now to
access those files from python so you
can do it uh via python and you can
actually read from indexeddb but we are
going to make that a bit easier so it's
a bit more seamless and a bit easier
easier to um
to do like real work with files that are
also on the server
uh but yeah the files on the server are
just static files right just like
everything is
from the jupyter lite website
um one thing you can do with files is
also share them so let's say you have
this redmi um this javascript you can
right click on that
copy shareable link and then you can
send it to someone
and they just paste the link in the
browser and it's going to open in a
couple of seconds with the two uh two
files that you send them uh that's quite
useful if you want to
quickly share something around
um
another thing that we've been working on
for a couple of days with
martin renu is this a new jupiter lab
extension um
so again it's a drip lab extension but
it works with jupiter light actually the
main motivation was to make it to work
with this so that we can
demo it today
so here you have another file browser uh
but it asks you to open the folder so
what happens here so i'm going to show
you um
yeah a full repo called pie chute so
it's like you know maybe you know it
it's like a set of notebooks and
explorations in python pretty nice
and let's say you want to use it in
light
this extension is using an experimental
non-standard browser api called the file
system access api
it's only available in chromium
based browsers so it's not working in
firefox yet so maybe it will never work
who knows so
what happens here is that it asks for
permission to open your your files so
remember here we are on github pages but
we access content from my machine using
this api and now we can
explore this
we can for example open this uh tsv file
which opens like you know almost like
excel
uh and we can also open other notebooks
if we want and you could for example
pick up something that you have on your
machine using
uh jupyter app website that someone else
deployed for you that could be one of
the use case for this for for this
um so yeah
um what else do we have yeah we have
also
real-time collaboration um so this is
again one thing that jupiterite is just
reusing from all of the work done
upstream in jupiter lab
so if you're interested by this you can
check the the talk by
kevin jones
by data global 2021 he goes you know
explains how it works and how it landed
in uh jupiter lab
and um it also works in jupiter light
but since there is no server the
approach is a bit different so jupyter 8
is using
a peer-to-peer uh via webrtc to sync the
changes between peers
so yeah that is also available
and i wanted to just show you a quick
look at
you know what it looks like under the
hood
so
there is no server is everything just
static
but still there is a server running
somewhere so it's running in a browser
of course
and the interesting thing is that it's
built almost the same way as jupiter lab
which is uh great because then we use
also a plug-in system so it means that
you can
use different
uh plugins for the server part let's say
you want to
upload your content somewhere else on
your private network in the company then
you could just swap that for something
else
and use private apis for example uh you
could have many kernels or none you
could also have this kind of
customization is is really just
available
yeah
so this brings us to kind of
where we've seen this going uh like the
past weeks so
we went a little bit further so we
started to also try to think of how can
we make that even simpler so
uh there is now a new uh rebel
application that is also shipped by
default in jupiter
light so if you're interested you can
check that
blog post on the jupiter blog we talk
about it a bit more
with more details
and what means is that you just you know
copy paste this
iframe code and you put it in your
website and let's say here you have a
jekyll website um then you have your
code console in your blog um so just for
the
the sake of it i did this on my
uh own website where i used to post some
stuff there but uh here
uh you see that if you scroll down um
you get the console and you can also
control the theme so here i put it in
dark
and you get the python running on the
on the jackal website which is uh
which is nice um
but once we started to explore this
other people started to say like they
wanted the same on their website so we
helped uh
numpy to also add this to an empire org
so if you go to numpy.org
you scroll down a little bit there is
this try numpy section so you can go
here
and uh the idea is you know we made it
so that you can copy paste from the left
to the right and you get you know numpy
in your browser
and
another example is um try jupiter
because um jupiter.org used to
well still using a binder to let you try
jupiter
uh in your browser without installing
anything locally but recently there has
been some issues with the funding
because
binder requires um
a lot of resources especially on google
cloud or ovh
and um
and these resources started to become a
bit scarce so
uh jupiter lights here came uh somewhat
to the rescue if i if i can say
so
here
um here if you click on the triptylab
icon uh it's going to launch a jupiter
light instead of full-blown jupiter but
we uh we thought that it would be
good enough because people who want to
try jupiter mostly want to try
the ui aspect of it so here you have
introduction to
notebooks
on trideut.jupiter.org
and
yeah it really helped reduce the load on
the binder
and here we have a
quick uh tweet by chris holgraf who
kind of said that this had a big impact
i think it kind of reduced by 30 or
maybe more
the load which is great
so we pretty much just
uh traded compute resources uh for just
static assets uh so that's that was a
big win
uh there is also now uh jupiter light
sphinx um which is a
extension to also
let you
use jupiter light in your darks so here
we have an example with ipad leaflet so
if applied leaflet is like ipad widgets
with
with uh interactive maps so if i go here
um
to the docs you actually have a notebook
so we saw the repo application but you
can also embed the notebook if you
prefer and here it's really nice because
users are landing on your docks they are
really just able to try it uh from the
start so there's nothing to do no
install
uh
yeah no
yeah nothing to install so that's uh
that's great so there is more to come
pandas is looking into adding that to
their talks as well uh senpai i think
it's uh let me check yeah it's still
open so it's almost there
but they will be adding uh this report
as well
and then we can start thinking about
yeah why not just uh why why not just
python
uh we could also have uh this for sql
for example uh so if you are more into
sql you can also use a sql lite kernel
for example and embed that on your
website if you want
so of course uh jupiter light has some
limitations
for now it's a bit more suited for
lighter workloads i mean things run in a
browser
still so you can do really you cannot do
like intensive computations at least not
yet
and you still need to install packages
with micro pip and pip light that come
from pyrolyte
this is going to be improved uh very
soon
because there is ongoing work to
leverage the whole conduct forge uh
infrastructure
um
accessing files from the python counter
is also a little bit clunky for now but
this is going to be
hopefully addressed at some point and
another aspect of it is that you need to
download quite a bit of
um things if you want to you know like
for the initial load but the good uh
good news is that
it is then cached by the browser so if
you reload the page afterwards your
browser should be able to cache most of
it so that's that's nice
and to finish
what is coming next is
a better way to expose files like i
mentioned um there is uh improved
package management management for web
assembly and quantum forge so there's
been a lot of work going on in a repo
called python wasm and it was started by
sm smith and now there are also
sea python core developers uh christian
and brett cannon uh working on it and
there is a keynote tomorrow on that so
if you're interested
um and there is also uh the future of
pie died so paradise was started by
michael drought boom and there is also
hood and roman working on it and now
torsten uh
is working on making that even better so
there is a lot of things happening on
the web assembly and that gpi will be
able to you know use all of this out of
uh out of the box
and we are working on um making better
code compression with maybe
it should work in browser lsp at some
point and uh
dashboards also we want them to work in
in a browser so you can publish
dashboards
without having to install anything on
your machine
and with this i would like to thank you
for coming and also a special thanks to
all of the contributors to uh
jupiter
[Applause]
thank you for the amazing talk we have a
lot of questions on online and i guess
we have a lot of questions here as well
do you have any questions can i see how
many people have questions
okay good then i will ask only the
online ones
um are there any questions or
suggestions work being done on getting
the initial size of payload lower
jupiter light may not work instantly
when loading it with slow internet
can you repeat it yes sure
are there any suggestions or work being
done on getting the initial size of
payload lower
jupiter light may not work instantly
when loading it in with slow internet
that's true that's very true but there
is um like i mentioned at the very end
um i think a lot of work is going on now
in actually see python itself which is
awesome because this is you know where
everything comes from and they are
uh really making
really amazing progress there because
it also has the um
side effect of reducing the binary size
and i think pi died also over the
different releases they managed to
reduce the
um the size uh to download like at least
the initial one yeah so there is uh it's
you know progressive but we're getting
there so yeah thank you
what are the performance differences for
libraries like numpy that would normally
make use of accelerations like be less
what about pytorch
tf with gpu
don't know if anyone tried it yet but
it's uh it's interesting because we were
just talking about it with a torso just
before uh the with the ongoing work uh
trying to reduce the condor forge
infrastructure maybe maybe uh pytorch
would be able to also run
in a browser so i think it's a big maybe
for now but i mean there is a
hope there for sure thank you
can dependencies be installed at runtime
or does every dependency need to be
statically compiled
no they can be installed at runtime so
so if we go back to some examples
you need to install them
on the fly
using
this micropip and the pip light is a
it's kind of a wrapper around micropip
for jupiter light so you can do this
but you can also if you want at least
for now you can also rebuild paradight
and include packages if you want
but
again like in the future this should
make it this would be much easier uh
once we have all of the building blocks
in place especially to reuse uh things
from conda yeah thank you
can jupiter light interact with git
can jupiter right interact with git
with git
we haven't tried but i think it should
um so
maybe it will have to use something a
different approach so
one thing that could be interesting is
to take inspiration from another project
called vs code.dev
and they uh it's like a vs code but
running in a browser so it's kind of
similar but uh not exactly and there is
also github.dev and they have support
for git so i would say
it should be possible also but we are we
haven't uh looked into it yet
thank you
how do you ensure the iframe embedding
option is safe
um yeah
well i mean in the end in jupiter you
execute code that's the the main feature
but uh you can also uh depends i mean it
always depends as usual but you can use
um sandboxing also otherwise
restrictions for iframes depending on
what you want to
to allow
thank you
do packages on condo forge need to be
modified in order to be installable by
jupiter light
um when we don't have it you know it's
still very
early stages so
now the idea would be to to just um
uh use the
set of recipes to produce the packages
but um uh ideally with uh almost no
medication at all yeah but i mean that's
the
the ongoing work
thank you one last question on the
online questions because we don't have
enough time how are shareable files
shared
how are shareable files shared shareable
files
so for now there are just uh links to um
to the files so
the thing i showed with this is that if
you if you go back here
uh it just creates a link uh like this
so i mean they are not sent to other
people it's just
redirecting you to an existing uh
deployment to an existing website so
um this is like the
easiest way to share files
but you can also if you want to use the
upload feature here and upload a file
that would then be
stored in the browser local storage
thank you
questions on the audience here
okay thank you for joining and thank you
for the talk
thank you